we are now seeing uh a second wave uh
coming in and we've
seen it in in france you see it in spain
across across europe it's been
absolutely i'm afraid inevitable that we
would see it
in this country roughly one-fifth of
britain's population is now under some
form of renewed culvert restrictions
tough decisions will have to be made as
the country heads into winter
but for now the prime minister says he
does not want
another full lockdown we want to keep
schools
open and it's fantastic that schools
have gone back in the way that they have
we want to keep
the economy open as far as we possibly
can we want to keep businesses
going but the only way we can do that is
obviously
if people follow the guidance london
mayor sadiq khan
says it is increasingly likely that
restrictions will be necessary in the
capital
to slow the spread of the virus he
believes now
is the time to act rather than later in
birmingham
the city's nightingale hospital which
had been mothballed
is now on high alert which means it
could be reopened within 72 hours
there is still the very real option of a
second national lockdown
possibly at half term in october but
would the public be prepared to make all
those sacrifices
again certainly the constant
maneuvering around different policy
arrangements
has been counterproductive it creates a
context where it's more likely for
police enforcement to be seen
as illegitimate so i think
interestingly we've just seen an attempt
to try to simplify the agenda
through the rule of six but in actual
fact what that's done is is create some
complications and some ambiguities about
what is and what
isn't allowed cases are now doubling
every seven to eight days
so two hospital admissions well demand
for culver testing has rocketed in
recent days
in some areas the r rate is now as high
as 1.4
public health england say that's a good
indicator that things could be about to
get a lot worse
as with so much of this crisis the
situation is constantly changing
the prime minister says when it comes to
getting culvert back under control
everything is now under review and de
brady sky news